foreign
[Music]
holy [__] [__]
I will tell you I've never seen anything
like it holy [__] [__]
is the craziest I think I've ever seen
everything okay
oh language the baby's here
yo what up everybody roaring Kitty here
I'm gonna pick a stock and talk about
why I think it's interesting and that
stock is Gamestop I love this guy
[Applause]
retail Traders get hooked into GameStop
I think they think it's a good
investment it looks like there's one guy
driving all the buying
money man happy to take it
Wall Street is betting that this company
is gonna fail if it fails these hedge
fund [__] make a [__] ton of money
70 000 people have watched this video
[Music]
let's drink to that my brother is a
[__] nerd Wall Street must be seeing
this right holy [__] [__] holy [__]
you should probably dial in holy [__]
[__] do you have a minute I uh
um babe how much should we make today
five million how much did we lose today
a billion and yesterday four million and
yesterday
a billion
yeah
[__] rich
you got rich dudes pissing in their
pants right now they're coming after you
we need to talk about the GameStop
situation
retail Traders always lose you've been
served Wall Street cheated surprise
surprise you have to testify before
Congress the game has changed
[Music]
we want to win the race if you let some
[__] steal the prize a lot of people
feel the system is broken the whole idea
of the stock market is if you're smart
and maybe with a little luck you can
make your fortune certainly not anymore
there's no hope for the little guy
[Music]
pit balls
maybe now there is [__] yeah
[Music]
foreign
just gonna turn a whole family into
millionaires
should I have a fashion line a
foundation
you're incredible today thank you I mean
it wasn't even like tennis it was an
entirely different day
[Applause]
hey come hang out with us later let me
come tuck you in no we just keep talking
[Music]
how often does this happen going after
the same girl not as often as you think
we usually have different types so
you're saying I should be flattered
aren't you everybody's type
which one of us
[Music]
he's not in love with you
what makes you think I want someone to
be in love with me it's nice to see lit
up about something even if it's my
girlfriend
foreign
's got his coach Tashi Donaldson who
also is his wife I'm playing for both of
us Tashi
I think maybe we're disturbed by the
fact that she could have been in a salon
like me when we were teenagers when we
were teenagers hey I love you
I know
you don't know what tennis is
it's a relationship
we went somewhere really beautiful
together
I'm taking such good care of my little
white boys
I assume you planned this not this part
best friends trip this is gonna be
iconic
you do understand this is a work trip
for me Audrey I got you look at me
you're thinking about a dick damn it
you're right look at me look at me look
at me now I love a grand Adventure I
heard that if you keep up with Chinese
businessmen they respect you more
you look like you've had a lot of things
in your [__] I'm not a lot of things
just one thing but maybe different
varieties of that one thing look at me
look at me look at me
if you do not know where you come from
how do you know who you are I'm just a
garbage American who only speaks English
and a little Golem
do you guys have that here yeah we have
it's the all over the world
are you horny
sex isn't shameful it's beautiful like
the noises oh
look
at me
show them there's some boards in this
house there's some boards in this house
I'm not racist you don't like Boba and
you never [__] an Asian guys damn
still when I masturbate I sometimes
fantasize about Splinter he's Asian he's
a rat he's a good father
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ers
because your mother is dead
she died because you sent her away she
was weak sick in her mind
you'll know my business yes
power is about strength
if you show weakness you will give our
enemies an opening
[Applause]
shot
thank you
this week like his mother leave him
what happened that day
I stared death in the face and for the
first time I saw my true self
tell me about this Hunter
they say he uses a connection with
animals to track his prey
once you're on his list
there's only one way off the six of us
and only one of you there's six of you
now
[Music]
why do you hunt my father puts evil into
the world
I take it out
[Music]
I think you're some kind of Honor you
were exactly like our father just
another man hunting foreign
[Music]
Mr tagline
Mr tackling
where's Mr tagley oh you're standing in
him
you're goddamn lunatic oh you just
figured that out now
there is an animal I need to wanna fast
don't you want to know why they call me
the rhino
you know what the greatest thing about
America is
you can make things happen here like
nowhere else
[Music]
to create your own future
you want to sell high-end stuffed
Himalayan cats understuffed actually for
greater posability we're professionals
we're giving the people what they need
okay
[Music]
did you see the latest numbers we broke
the entire internet thing
man or you go home
[Music]
I would tell you he did it all
which is as crazy as believing the
stuffed animals are gold
do you see the truck
insane poor beanies
this has always been my company company
we created together you have to be so
dramatic I mean my salary's been reduced
75 yeah I'm just doing what's necessary
you know running the real actual
business over here
[Music]
my life is this company can I see where
it's going wow there are signs of real
trouble genius is one percent
inspiration 99 presentation
that's not how the saying goes
everything good that's happened to me is
because of you guys we are bonded
forever
have you considered poisoning him
countless times
I have our perfect Partners lined up
Jehovah's Witnesses the greatest
one-on-one salesman in the world how
brilliant is that
[Music]
um
I only want to speak to Oprah Winfrey
has she reached out
when our world is threatened
one team is ready to Launch
to say lunch uh no I said launch
[Music]
it's giving off some kind of energy
I didn't do it
no way this September I think we got
super powers
and that's why I wear a hard hat
[Music]
look at your paws
now the clumsy pup shoots Fireballs out
of his paws
Paw Patrol but more but just a little
bit extra
how about
the mighty pups
those would be my superpowers
take them one by one
oh my goodness I could talk
so much to say give me that
it's showtime
he looks different than I remember
one of us
you go up against all of us
now that we're super I'm never gonna get
to sleep well you're probably more tired
than you
oh you've got to be kidding me
[Music]
I was practically the only non-white
person in my entire high school and you
never felt discriminated again I
definitely did but not because I was
Asian because of your inherent bad
personality exactly
do you remember that with that
internship that I applied for what about
it it's
it's New York is overrated it's so
gentrified now how many times have you
even been there are we counting layovers
you always assume the worst about me and
then you end up acting crazy over
nothing I'm not acting crazy so stop
using that word
you're just proving my point
are you two like broken up we're taking
some time off while the cat's away the
mouse will play with himself probably
can I kiss you
sorry I'm a little out of practice
it's clear
[Music]
I'm gonna go to New York listen maybe
you could come with me I thought you
came out here to clear your head I did
and then I met Meredith and I've been
there ever since so when are you gonna
see her I'm here to see Miko she's an
intern here actually I'm the only intern
here
there's some problems with anger
depression your
[Music]
I know you're going to want to blame
this on society or on your race or
whatever but this really is just about
you this is your rock bottom
you doing with that guy they're being
adorable
finally get to meet you mysterious
boyfriend
is anyone sitting here
no
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
what about boys at school must be some
hams and ones
[Applause]
[Music]
for centuries we have called out to the
universe
looking for answers
in 2024
the universe
calls back
bring us your lead
[Music]
[Applause]
hi can you hear me honey now is a really
bad time okay
bye
I love you I love you I love you
[Music]
this is new
whoa please State the name of your
Homeworld uh Earth welcome leader of
Earth
we are the United Advanced species of
the Universe I think there's been a
mistake you're not the leader of Earth
sorry for the mix-up commence memory
wise
I am the leader of Earth why is your
voice different uh I've always talked
like this since I was a kid which I'm
obviously not anymore but yes I run the
planet the trial of Earth can proceed
uh-oh until then as you say on Earth
okay bye I love you okay okay
the talk of the communiverse if Mom
could see me now I know what you mean I
ate my mother at Birth but in moments of
great success I regret it that's a thing
for your species no just a me thing
everyone was shocked
[Music]
you know you really captured his Essence
maybe his face could use a little more
detail though
it's like a photograph I'm Adam Chloe
[Music]
so you're not gonna make fun of me
all right
oh my God
this might be the nicest thing anyone's
ever done for me
[Music]
you have 62 viewers and 300 total
they don't have love in their culture
they find romantic stuff super exotic
and
interestingly watch you'll go on dates
one of our most cherished human rituals
[Music]
the broadcast
hey would you keep that [__] out of my
line of sight why don't you keep your
[__] out of our line of sight you didn't
invent courtship broadcast [__]
yeah
[Music]
it has recently become obvious you are
deceiving your viewers what deceiving
the title love your broadcast is Adam
and Chloe in love and yet you are not in
love
oh fun you have received
everything wait we've already spent
everything we made just to live
then I will take you to court and your
families will be in debt for
approximately six Generations
do you want me to cut that for you
where is the nearest restaurant
no part of my body can make that noise
well it certainly won't if you don't try
we can get that love back
romantic love is the most poetic of all
human love gods it should never be faked
unders like any other person I want to
grow up and fall in love and be swept
off my feet
will come a lot too
[Music]
foreign
I heard it again
no more nightmares tonight okay champ
[Music]
this is getting ridiculous
this is an old house
there's bound to be bumps in the night
Peter Drew this yes is he all right
Peter has an overactive imagination
[Music]
no more nightmares no more that's right
you know I wish I had someone I could
talk to about the things that were
happening in my house Mom
[Music]
[Applause]
laughs
mom
[Music]
Peter sometimes
you have to make hard decisions to
protect your family
what is that
the banging
[Music]
all right
you don't hear anything Peter
[Music]
it's going to get you into trouble one
day
[Music]
abilities I detect Young
at five or six
maybe we can start with a name
Aurora
[Applause]
[Music]
like normal people bro
these abilities only work of you are in
control
[Music]
so what's his name who's name we're not
playing that game you want to keep
secrets and she'll be better in your
mind how about you stand on my head and
give me some privacy
I ask you about your abilities I like to
do projections you say you hate what we
read and yet you love that garbage
that's good can you move objects I'm not
good at it you need a teacher Rob his
abilities they're complicated they're
transformative
and they can be dangerous underneath
let's go come on I'm not going with you
[Music]
mom I need you to start telling me the
truth no more lies just trying to give
you the tools to protect yourself who
a this
is
freaking out
kids please
foreign
10 days all expenses paid get out of
town for a little while
okay look no you can think about it
why are you smiling I just got some good
news about my trip
[Music]
you must be crazy if you think that I'm
getting this thing with you behind the
wheel I don't know how to drive
It's gotta be a nightmare
so are you gonna
it's about
about finding my
mom she's from Spain over the last two
years I've been doing a lot of research
and I came up with 10 mother candidates
that way that way
just wondering if you had a daughter
[Music]
I'm around a lot 12 different homes in
my 18 years in the system
[Music]
add up with all the unanswered questions
what happened to her
what's my family life it's just the only
thing I have reverse
I got a better idea
Where You Are
look at your mom's signature does Maria
asked Sierra's what if it said Maria
ostiros and I just found an address
[Music]
I've died and gone to Venus oh you're
certainly not from this world
[Music]
hello there inspect the sun world famous
detective
New York All Aboard careful with that
relax sweetie it's a honeymoon tickets
Mr guilty it's pronounced
it's French
[Music]
who is she that's baroness Black Widow
Arabella kill top Dr spinderthorpe
inspector's son listen I'm the
wealthiest bug on this flying boat I
believe my life is in danger with all
due respect doctor collage is not a
dangerous hobby I want you watching my
back what I believe is you have an
overactive imagination and a dangerous
wife
ah
Sonic we need you it's been a murder
we're not looking for one killer but two
maybe three
do I hear four four it was her someone
clearly doesn't want you looking into
this Bugsy case
I know someone tried to off me
Don't Panic Arabella you're putting us
both in terrible danger save me son
let's go partner
Stop in the Name of the law
I am on my own and uh you got a little
something on your uh never mind
you work here
no Esther I'm picking up your trash
because I don't work here
Dad don't forget you have a
dermatologist appointment today also
King deposit mom's disability check
growing up I was told my parents were
special when I got old enough I realized
that's the word adults use when someone
has a disability who's that he looks
thirsty look at her the part of her
brain that makes her horny is still
working she just wants to give him
something to drink it's the worst that
could help them
[Music]
I don't think they can take care of a
child what choice do we have my mother
named me after her favorite cartoon
character hi Bambi now you know what B
is short for but hey at least we were
happy
I know Bee's childhood was somewhat
non-traditional I don't want to do this
anymore you said it'll be fun and it's
not fun you gotta learn how to drive I'm
10. but that hasn't stopped her from
enjoying it well everyone was busy
worrying about my future still waiting
on those college applications I know I
was just trying to balance work school
and caring for my parents is that why
you never want me to come over no it's
okay everyone's embarrassed by the
parents
hi come on in man with your grades and
extracurriculars you have a shot of
getting into any college I can't you can
no I mean I can't leave
my whole life I've been torn between
wanting to get away from my parents
and wanting to care for them maybe
because you do everything for them
convince yourself that they're helpless
[Music]
we spent a very long time worrying about
other people
is time to focus on you for a while
we are our family but one of these days
are going to move out get married that's
what kids are supposed to do a whole new
world with an unknown future shoot for
the stars you like the roof
it's kind of a messed up saying
what does it feel to have everything
planned out because I feel like I'm in
control
I wish I could just turn my brain off
[Music]
your lucky day your dream girl's single
you want to relax she hasn't been single
for in 10 minutes
[Music]
so what are you guys doing tonight Dell
topia
[Music]
yeah it's college party in the country
to come
[Music]
deltopia
asking Jack for drugs you like him I
don't really he's just a friend
hello do you know anyone that could get
us Molly yeah we know somebody
[Music]
you want to pop up Molly you want to get
this
[Music]
yeah if you have just finished high
school and have the world at your
fingertips what are you guys gonna do
without each other we ride together we
die together Jack
you guys are chill right
not gonna have to call you mommy please
there's one thing I learned from my mom
it's how to mix my drugs and alcohol
[Music]
hell no
hundreds of college
[Music]
what happened to you started a riot
just regular Friday
[Music]
fear Nathan
it engulfs you
plagued by your nightmarish memories
unless you are Vigilant you will drown
in fear
the end of days are nigh
the metal Oculus is upon us
um hi
what the Doom star
closer to our atmosphere every day
threatening cataclysmic destruction
salacia only he knows what vile Evils
are in store
we must Journey out to find the song of
salvation
what is the song of Salvation
well do we at least know the running
time rough company now does we at least
knows what keys
what happens if we do it wrong
the world will be made in blood
will be dead
now is the time for you to choose
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]